un petit 10 minutes qui pourrait sauver
jusqu'à trois vies alors que l'été bat
son plein héma québec prévient que ses
réserves de sang diminue présentement la
situation disons de s'en aller pas
inquiétante mais par contre elle est
préoccupante comme c'est l'été puis tout
le monde est en vacances on a 500 dons
de plus à faire par semaine par contre
c'est chez les groupes sanguins à
positif et en négatif que les besoins
sont les plus importants la reprise des
voyages à l'étranger est l'un des
facteurs qui expliquent la baisse des
réserves cet été il ya un impact un peu
partout c'est à dire que on a l'habitude
dans des bases fils de m en saison
estivale les québécois ont pris d'assaut
cette année des aéroports surtout après
deux ans et demi donc l'absence de fait
sortir malheureusement mégane le mieux
est une donneuse régulière depuis l'an
dernier elle en est à son 20e dont je
trouve que maxime cause qui est
importante le il ya tellement de gens
qui ont besoin de fraude sont gay à
chaque année comme elle stéphane morin a
fait du don de sang une habitude il en a
déjà donné plus de 450 fois pour moi
c'est bon atteint puisque chez jay les
opi jamais douchy pour ceux qui hésitent
à prendre rendez vous héma-québec vous
conseille d'inviter vos proches à tenter
l'expérience avec vous souvent on a des
groupes qui se présentent soit des
familles des amis des gens qui prennent
rendez vous ensemble pour se motiver à
groix la réserve
aux
québécois héma québec invite tous les
adultes intéressés à faire un don de
sang à se rendre sur son site web pour
vérifier s'ils sont admissibles et pour
prendre rendez vous ici flavie sauvageau
radio canada québec